so ultimately I think what I'm saying is
on a scale of one to six I rate this as
an Avengers tower so one of those things
that I just feel like talking about
don't really have an impetus for it's
not something I get asked about a ton
but every now and then it comes up and I
guess I kind of want to explain my
philosophy which is not that complicated
which means this will probably be a
short video
I don't do ratings when I review movies
or TV shows or anything else I never
have and I never will
there was a brief time when I debated
sort of coming up with my own rating
system a bit like what Jeremy Jones does
but it's funny like I think it was
earlier this year he had to rien
tried to break it down as a standard
like a 1 to 6 number thing is like it's
not meant to work like that so I'm glad
I didn't try and implement my own
version ultimately the main reason I
don't give a rating is because well
there's a number of reasons the first is
is that I mean maybe it's egotistical I
kind of want you to hear my actual
thoughts on a thing and if I had ratings
I know there would be a decent
percentage of people who would just
click to the last 30 seconds of the
video find out the rating and never
watched the rest of the review and
especially if it was a rating that they
didn't agree with either it was high on
something they didn't like or low on
something they did like they would rant
in the comments that mean based solely
off that number and with no regard for
what I said and actually that's kind of
a secondary thing what I a big thing
that I don't like about numbered ratings
or at least in terms of why I won't do
them is it gets it removes all the
nuance so like a lot of stuff that I
talked about here whether it be on TV or
movies or whatever I tend to either like
with a couple of nitpicks or dislike
while recognizing some of the things
that
work there I I don't think there's all
that many times that I review something
that it's either the best thing ever or
the worst thing ever and so trying to
boil down that kind of nuance into
nothing more than a number
first of all honestly it would just
stress me out I don't like having to
think in terms of of that especially
because once you start using numbered
ratings or any rating system actually
there are people out there and that will
start to basically keep track and then
throw it back in your face
so if for whatever reason I chose to
like we're good again this is regardless
of the context of what I said in the
review if I chose to even Avengers
infinity war and nine and the Godfather
and eight for whatever my reasons might
be for doing that if I did that and
that's not me saying what I would number
those as this is a for instance if I did
that there would be people going oh my
god you think marvel's is better than
The Godfather I'm like oh for God's sake
cuz that's the thing the minute you
assign a number to things people take it
as a as like a hot piece of hard data
but I'm giving opinion an opinion is not
made up of hard data so I don't like
giving anyone the ammunition to try and
break down my thoughts on you know
through the use of quote-unquote hard
data or we know that he liked this
better than and that's another thing
with ratings so like if I'm rating what
do I do with something that I can
recognize was very well done but what it
was doing was not something I enjoy do I
give it more points than my enjoyment
would indicate on its technical
instructional merits do I take something
that I know is a deeply flawed film but
that I loved personally do i dock it
down more do i boost it up up and over
things like I don't I hate the idea of
having to make those calculations and
like the closest I come to doing any of
that is rankings I will do you know
rankings but that's always relic
that's always lumping a bunch of a
similar thing together like ranking the
Marvel movies ranking Doctor Who
episodes and stacking them up against
each other even that I will never assign
numbers to the Internet these days makes
it hard for you to change your feelings
about something and if you assign a
number to something it's treated like it
should be an immutable fact so if at a
later date a movie I talked about a
movie that I gave say a really high
rating too and I talked about you know
the issues with it I'm gonna have that
high rating thrown back in my face like
but before you said this whereas if I
just stick to talking my opinion and not
even assigning a rating to it I feel
like I get a little bit more leeway for
those feelings and those opinions to
change now am I saying that no critics
should use ratings of course not this is
called they're all gonna make you know
on their own and I absolutely understand
ratings for someone who is a
professional critic but I'm not I'm just
I'm just somebody rambling at a camera
so I'm not employed by anyone to do this
my thoughts are not being consolidated
on you know on Metacritic or Rotten
Tomatoes or whatever nobody cares
well I mean I think you folks here but I
mean like in terms of the the scope of
criticism I'm not in that world now if
someone does consider themselves to be a
legitimate critic like you could make an
argument that they should be because
part of professional criticism is for
lack of a better term sort of consumer
advocacy you are advising consumers that
this is something that they should take
they should partake in or that they
should avoid and assigning a number to
that does help with that element of
professional criticism but again I I'm
lucky if I get to these things opening
night um I'm not getting to
pre-screening so I I don't imagine
there's a lot of people maybe there's a
few but I can't
there's a lot of people who are waiting
for my review before they decide whether
or not they're gonna go see something
and again I suspect that that number so
small that they maybe they want to hear
my whole thoughts on it we'll see
but yeah ratings are there there have
been various points over times where
I've been asked you know will you do
this will you do that and I've said no I
will never do that and more often than
not I've ultimately perjured myself on
that because often times you know if
it's about a certain topic the mere
asking will you talk about this gets me
thinking about if it's something that I
care about like I I still get people
asking me like will I ever review Sonic
the Hedgehog anything and the answer to
that is just it's just no it's not my
fandom I don't have a dog in that race
I'm sorry but you know so aside from
sort of those sort of situations I do
have it I have had a tendency in the
past to say no I will never talk about
this and then ultimately end up doing it
here though I'm drawing a hard line I'm
never never gonna do ratings cuz for me
and what I do and my approach to this
there's no benefit for me to do that
it's nothing but a hassle it's stress
for me to try and figure it out
especially if I'm gonna worry about the
precedent of what other things I have or
haven't given this rating or a higher or
lower rating before knowing that other
people out there are keeping track I
don't buy I just know I never want to
deal with that that takes away enjoyment
from me for doing this so those are my
reasons why I don't use a rating system
not numbers not grades not what I made
up and I never will so rating systems
what are your thoughts on them do you
have a preferred one do you like an 8 an
A+ to F do you like a stars rating do
you like like the unique custom ones
that some reviewers have come up with
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it whole bunch of stuff you can do
because there's buttons and there's
links including a link to my patreon if
you're in a generous mood if not though
don't worry about it you know there's
other stuff that you can click on down
there don't want to click on that that's
ok too because at the end of the day you
are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this count
Sol is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]